lo que quiero hacer en estos vídeos es
intentar ver qué le sucede a una
integral de línea ya sea sobre un campo
escalar o bien sobre un campo vectorial
cuando recorremos la trayectoria en
dirección contraria déjame hacer un
dibujo para explicar esto supongamos que
tomamos una trayectoria hace dada de la
siguiente forma voy a dibujar el plano
xy aquí vamos a poner el eje y aquí
abajo el eje x la trayectoria comienza
en este punto de aquí conforme se mueve
empieza a recorrer algo en el plano y al
final llega a este punto de acá la
trayectoria está recorriendo se en esta
dirección ahora a lo que me refiero con
recorrer en el sentido contrario es que
vamos a tomar una curva - que se ve más
o menos así este de aquí es el eje de
este lado tenemos el eje x y menos se va
a empezar
al final entonces va a empezar aquí
arriba y va a empezar a recorrer en el
sentido contrario hasta llegar al punto
inicial es decir es exactamente la misma
curva pero como trayectoria le estamos
recorriendo en el otro sentido lo que
voy a hacer en el resto del vídeo es ver
cómo podemos pasar
parametrización original a la
parametrización de la inversa después en
los siguientes dos vídeos veré cómo
afecta este cambio a las integrales de
línea de campos escalares y de campos
vectoriales va entonces vamos a pasar a
la parametrización de la curva c vamos a
ponerlo en la forma en la cual lo
ponemos siempre vamos a escribir x es
igual a x dt perdón de t y es igual al
dt y vamos a poner que se mueve en un
cierto intervalo desde te iguala no
déjame escribirlo con desigualdades
mejor te empiecen a o sea a menor o
igual que t y llega hasta b va vámonos
al dibujo este punto de aquí es el punto
inicial entonces es para t iguala a
vamos a escribir el punto con
coordenadas este punto corresponde a x
de a coma idea ahora vámonos al punto
final cuando te des igual ave estamos en
este punto de aquí déjame recorrer un
poco la pantalla para tener espacio
entonces este punto de aquí es para t
igual a b y cuáles son sus coordenadas
pues sus coordenadas son x debe coma dv
sale hasta ahorita nada nuevo ahora dada
esta parametrización cómo podemos
construir una nueva que tenga
exactamente la misma curva pero que
comience aquí o sea aquí queremos que
déjame mejor cambiar de colores para que
nos quede un poco más claro esto
entonces aquí este punto rosa mexicano
va a ser te iguala entonces conforme te
aumenta queremos llegar hasta aquí hasta
de igual ave fíjate en la diferencia
queremos movernos en la dirección
contraria
entonces párate igual a lo que queremos
es que las coordenadas sean de todas
formas x debe como htv es decir cuando
te es igualada quiero que aquí aparezca
un ave en cada una de estas funciones y
párate igual ave quiero lo contrario
quiero que nos quede el punto x de a
coma idea fíjate cómo esto invierte los
papeles con respecto a lo que pasaba
antes entre igualada teníamos estos
puntos y aquí entre igual a ver tenemos
estos mismos puntos
ahora vamos a pasar a cómo hacer esto
algebraica mente pero antes vamos a
pensar un poquito fíjate para cuando te
sea igualada queremos que aquí aparezca
una vez
o sea que xy estén devaluadas en b
entonces vamos a definir x de la
siguiente forma vamos a ponerle x es
igual a x de esta misma x es más de
hecho voy a ponerlo con el mismo color
que lo puse antes x es igual a x de y
entonces en vez de poner te vamos a
hacer lo siguiente para cambiar la
dirección vamos a poner más b menos te
ok entonces cerramos el paréntesis y
ahora pasemos allí entonces también
tenemos es igual a head
y vamos a poner lo mismo vamos a
escribir a más ve - de ojo los tonos de
amarillo son muy parecidos se va vamos a
ver qué le sucede a estas expresiones
cuando las evaluamos en los extremos
vamos a pasar te iguala entonces aquí le
voy a escribir t igual no espérame
tantito antes dejar de poner que esta
parametrización también empieza en nada
y te es menor o igual que be ok entonces
vamos a confirmar que en efecto queda
esta misma curva pero recorrida en
dirección contraria hagamos las cuentas
para los extremos entonces vamos a
escribir qué pasa cuando te es igual a
para cuando te es igual a a tenemos lo
siguiente tenemos que x va a ser igual a
x d
v - a verdad aquí tenemos menos t y t es
igual a entonces tenemos menos a lo cual
es igual a que puede saber a con menos a
se cancelan y simplemente nos queda x
dv listo de modo similar para cuando te
es igual a desigual h de amas ve - a las
se cancelan y esto nos queda igual
dv ok entonces estoy aquí funciona para
cuando te es igual a nuestra
parametrización nos queda x debe como
may rv entonces para t iguala estamos en
este punto de aquí vale veamos si
podemos hacer lo mismo para cuando usted
es igual a b déjame organizar un poquito
esto de aquí voy a poner una línea de
este lado y voy a recorrer un poco la
pantalla para seguir con esta parte
entonces lo voy a escribir para cuando
te des igual ave por aquí entonces para
cuando te es igual a b que tenemos
tenemos que x es igual a x d
b - b verdad además ve - t pero te es
igual a b
entonces eso de ahí es igual a equis de
a y que suceden y pues igual es igual al
de b b y eso de ahí es igual a que de
ahí sale entonces los puntos extremos
funcionan y si lo piensas intuitivamente
conforme te se mueve para cuando te es
igualada nos quedan los valores x dvi
que debe que es lo que hicimos aquí
abajo conforme te aumenta entonces esta
expresión a más ve menos te va a empezar
a decrecer desde donde pues desde b
empieza en b y luego empieza a decrecer
poco a poco hasta llegar a lo voy a
poner así empieza en b y llega hasta a
por supuesto la primera empieza en a y
llega hasta b ya después con un
argumento extra se puede justificar que
en efecto se recorre toda la curva y en
sentido contrario sale salvo quizás lo
del argumento extra espero que me creas
que esta parametrización en efecto nos
da la misma curva pero en la cual la
trayectoria está recorrida en dirección
contraria es decir empieza donde termina
y termina donde empieza
saleh ya teniendo esto lo que quiero
hacer en el siguiente vídeo es comparar
la integral de línea sobre ce de fx y de
ese con a ver déjame aclarar un poquito
aquí tenemos la integral de línea de un
campo escalar efe sobre esta curva de
acá verdad o más bien sobre esta
trayectoria entonces lo que quiero hacer
es comparar con la integral sobre
exactamente el mismo campo escalar fx y
de ese pero sobre la nueva trayectoria
menos eso lo vamos a hacer en el
siguiente vídeo y en el que le sigue
vamos a ver qué pasa si f es un campo
vectorial